ah yes the good old days when Disney
logos didn't have to conform to whatever
movie well as opposed to the Galactic
Federation headquarters on planet Zenzi
on dr. jumba jookiba why does this space
Court have the defendant standing on
some sort of a floating pod while he's
being read the charges it always seems
like movies do this to make things look
out of this world but I have a lot of
logistical questions for these aliens
and I'm Charles stupid when they explain
why because they're aliens and more
advanced don't have centuries of floaty
pod knowledge that I don't have well at
least now we know why Disney is going so
heavy with the remakes far be it from me
to give Disney new spin-off ideas but if
it's gonna happen I need a full TV
series on Disney Plus about this sign
I'd teddy bear I'm assuming his name is
mr. Pooh qiamat fluff and tuft man he's
fed up with your bullshit
what is that monstrosity I guess I'm
supposed to be appalled by stitch but do
I think the other multi-armed many i
Italians are normal not two feet from
you there's an octopus with the robot
body but he's cool
what the hell is this that's just the
number three looks like someone was
struggling with a bout of glitters block
everyone reacts to a made-up language
like they just said something super
offensive even though everyone has been
speaking English up until now cliche are
we going to get subtitled alien
locations for every new room I think we
get the idea without having it spelled
out even the kiddos in fact especially
the kiddos the council has banished you
to exile on a desert asteroid the space
council follows the precedent set by the
parallax case and simply banishes stitch
despite calling him a product of a
deranged mind why let space handle this
when you could just keep stitch in this
indestructible glass jar these guns are
locked onto your genetic signature again
indestructible jar why was he taken out
of that why is there a prisoner system
dedicated to genetically long guns when
you have the jar these look like pretty
complicated and well thought out genetic
cannons for no-one to have considered
the saliva corollary what game is this
hammerhead plate he's holding these
things like cards but isn't he the only
one in the room is there a solitaire
game where you hold your cards in your
hand like this also some asshole who was
hired to pay attention isn't paying
attention so that the movie can happen
cliche
but he hasn't escaped yet armadillo
alien can see the future those lasers
just blasted through a security door a
moment ago but now they can't penetrate
this material stitches looking pretty
badass but his escape isn't adding up I
smell an inside job why they always put
the power grid next to the ventilation
system rookie mistake spacecraft
builders also are we sure stitch knocked
out the power captain shoot now and ask
later is looking like a strong candidate
for the Institute report stitch starts
shooting at the fleet man I guess the
fleet can't be bothered to shoot his
ship down because after all he was
banished and not sentenced to death and
you must follow the court's orders no
matter what stitch activates the
hyperdrive which wait why does this
small alien police ship have a
hyperdrive pretty sure I read somewhere
or saw in a movie completely unrelated
to this that said something about little
ships not being capable of hyperdrive
and I'm sticking to that made-up rule
that I can't properly reference quadrant
17 section zero zero five area 51
har-har you speak our language fluently
how do you not know our planet's name we
have to guess the planet conveniently
quirky scientist who just happens to
know everything about Earth and has a
viewmaster presentation at the ready
even though it just came up in the last
60 seconds is quirky inconvenient earth
there's a protected wildlife reserve
yeah we've been using it to rebuild the
mosquito population which need I remind
you is an endangered species okay haha
got your joke in but how many god damn
mosquitoes do you need before your
rebuild is done can you guys come take a
few billion the next time you're here
that would be swell can we not simply
destroy the island amazing to me that
this head council member decided to
banish stitch earlier but was ready to
gas an entire planet to kill stitch just
a second ago I thought the reason why
they banished him was because of some
sort of opposition to the death penalty
now I realize it was just a plot device
why is this headline in English and the
rest of this article written in what I
can only assume is the native language
of cats who walk across keyboards also
how does an alien ship put out a
newspaper about Jumba mere hours after
the incident and why are no aliens
publishing newspapers and he's been in
jail for an hour and already as a photo
collection mckennon granted do we have a
bargain
okay jumbo sure give the guy who just
self described himself as an evil genius
applies mechanic because this seems like
exactly the thing that will bring about
solutions you're Vonda did it better
is there an ideas Union now this is one
of the weirdest great
ever put into a film based on a freaking
idea Chris we're gonna go with your idea
but we can only pay you idea money and
you will be compensated as such I know
that's not as much as three money fuck
times are tight every one of the full
world can see there's four girls coming
out for this song but this guy counts
each one is if it's difficult to see
that a fifth one is missing
also this never would have happened if
he had cast Moana instead it's a good
thing this waters decided to wait to be
slippery until after the song so this
discount pepper and couldn't slip on it
while standing still instead of well you
know dancing around on me you're a lying
asshole little girl during this entire
sequence lilo lays a fistful of
smackdown on you and never once bites or
has the chance to bite your arm okay so
Nani was on the way to pick up lilo and
her massive failure of a dance recital
only to find out that lilo had left
before she got there but how did lilo
get back to the house without Nani
seeing her since it appears there's only
one way to get here furthermore how did
lilo have time to nail the door shut man
I guess she also did this to the back
door since Nani isn't even trying and
why doesn't she have a house key also
how is this supposed to indicate that
lilo nailed the door shut by pounding
nails partially into a frame how does
this magic work you left the stove on
while you were out
a social worker arrives at house and an
unusual amount of crazy bull goes wrong
during their visit cliche also Nami is a
terrible human being you should have
lilo taken away from her immediately and
no amount of animated book redemption
will change my mind on this my friends
need to be punished just in case you
forgot that our protagonist was a
six-year-old psychopath will be is here
to remind you every few seconds in case
you're wondering this did not go well
you have three days to change my mind
how the fuck does that work you already
suspect the worst Oh what does three
days do this isn't a failed emissions
test where you either fix your car or
you who's one of the many cheats to pass
on it like quite literally it looks like
all Nani has to do is clean the house
and make sure the front door isn't
nailed shut and she'll be considered a
fit Guardian intricate and unnecessary
plan you know she's in the washer and
it's not like she really has anywhere to
go if you open that door can we talk for
a sec about Lilo's early-onset fat
fetish at some point a childhood quirk
of photographing large white people's
close up places becomes something to
discuss with a professional otherwise
you might grow up to be Tom for
directing nocturnal animals this
dickhead was shooting drops of water a
second ago but now when he encounters an
actual living thing he gets sudden
discipline where are all these guns even
coming from Oh
the jump I even know to find stitch II
the aliens only knew he landed on the
island but couldn't possibly have known
that a trucker ran him over and took him
to an animal shelter a dot plus-- today
I think it was dead this morning
wait but when stitch woke up he was in a
kennel with several other dogs are you
in the habit of tossing presumed
deceased animals into your cages and why
not call it that while you're at it look
awesome shout out to the animation
studios that helped make lilo & stitch
possible but what a ridiculous place to
put it it's like you're saying that the
characters in this movie can't see it or
won't read it and wonder what the fuck
it's talking about Allen even contains
the name Lila and the name lilo gives
the creature right after this contract
to suck which would make me think this
animal shelter dabbles in witchcraft
this hearing is great which means he
also should have heard everything before
this including whatever Jumba said is
this movie the middle of the road is not
an appropriate place to apologize for
biting someone feel like this would be
covered in kindergarten rent that big
wheel
coloring book shaving you sure it's a
dog so many more people should be asking
this exact question I mean even if you
don't know it's an alien we are all
going koala before dog with this right
and yes I know she mentions that later
but it wouldn't even take a full second
to know this isn't a dog did you catch
fire again god help this movie if I see
someone do one Mockingjay gesture I
gotta go the kid at Table three thrown
POI again because how else would Hawaii
be a character in this movie if it
wasn't for the casual POI reference wait
these assholes were in the restaurant
the whole time and nobody thought it was
weird that a green Cyclops in drag and a
dude with obviously more than two eyes
was sitting there what are the odds that
while thrift shopping for his second
disguise of the day Pleakley he
discovered the world's strongest weight
glue the manager's of vampire he wanted
me to join his legion of the undead I
almost said I'd rather watch that movie
but I'm pretty sure that's the plot to
Hotel Transylvania 3 so I'm good is this
movie seriously trying to tell me that
they haven't been home once since they
got stitch was a Dumbo in this tray
earlier you must have flown away return
of Dumbo a sequel that should never be
made the Golden Gate Bridge even when
it's a model is in some sort of danger
cliche
I will try log no B has time for this
yeah but mosquitoes make their living by
not hurting you when they bite their
Chris they bite you then they leave and
then your itchy and all you want is
revenge and you'll never get it why does
this shadow have four arms when stitch
is clearly operating with two okay fine
so lilo for some reason has voiced ur
farming and fire-eating vocational
guides in a room why are the covers
printed on the back of the book I'm not
the front it's almost like it's meant
for the audience she's sad because he's
all alone and nobody wants him but on
this page his family hears him crying
and he fine can this abridge story of
the ugly duckling completely misses the
pointed story of the ugly duckling he
wasn't just lost and found
he was mocked and considered himself an
outcast but grew into a beautiful swan
anyway if he wanted to go with the Lost
and Found thing just go with are you my
mother the part where the bird asks the
excavator if it birthed him was always
my favorite new model who dis but I
cannot ignore you being jobless do I
make myself clear this is just a
reminder that the social services guy
even exists you said he'd be back in
three days so I don't understand why
he's back now just to give Nani a
warning unplanned synchronized
choreography first off I'm not sure how
this acoustic guitar makes a noise high
enough to break glass second off nobody
is amazed at the dog that is currently
playing a guitar like a god while I'm
amused with all the hijinks being a
tremendous hijinks fan these little
vignettes make me continue to be judgey
about nannies parenting skills she lost
her job because of lilo and stitch she's
failed at her job interviews because of
them and there apparently is no end in
sight to their undisciplined behavior
yet she keeps bringing them with her on
every single interview expecting them to
wait quietly whenever she leaves them
huh this didn't impress the people at
the diner a minute ago but the people at
the beach sure seemed to understand how
incredible this is I guess all the
ancillary characters in this movie go
along with whatever the movie needs them
to do this is supposed to be a sad
moment but I will refer you to the
multiple sins where I talked about how
terrible apparent Nani is and how she
didn't bother to do anything after three
failed interviews I know that there's no
better cure for a sour face and a couple
of boards and some choice waves I think
that's a great idea
does this boards and waves thing you're
talking about me and she'll get a job
because that's the main issue with her
life right now the social services guide
demands it and there's a time crunch we
now take you to the surfing
dodj because this movie that can barely
stretch past 80 minutes would rather
spend its precious time on another song
then the whole space story part that we
haven't checked in on in the last 20
minutes even though I'm thinking it's
the center of this one thing I've heard
about to call the plot awesome I know
nothing about surfing but isn't riding
on with a little girl on it dangerous
like it might change the weight and the
maneuverability of the board I don't
know which is while Senate and ask for
forgiveness later
I mean Leslie Lowe even holding on to on
this board kind of assholes do this
Nanni's tireless job search continues
but the poor woman just can't drum up
any luck something is not right
six is returning to water alright
because it was mentioned once in this
movie that he was too tense to survive
in water or something yada yada plot
something yada yada family yada yada
closing song move on
jumper completely pulls up the Meg on
stitch here and I can't decide what's
more ridiculous but he could swim that
well or that this is the moment he
chooses to make his move what's he been
waiting for this guy's been following
them the whole time I have no idea why
he hasn't gone ahead and put lilo in a
foster home can't imagine what he's seen
that gives Nani the benefit of the doubt
unless mad surfing skills is a box you
can fill on the good Guardian checklist
you need to think about what's best for
lilo even if it removes you from the
picture this is 100 percent apps a
freaking lutely trick and I'm not sure
why the movie is trying to convince us
otherwise
oh I asked the traditional Hawaiian song
you've seen when social services
declares you an unfit Guardian just like
Colonel James Harbottle Boyd intended a
test before Disney remember there must
be a dead parent or two in every movie
sure it's alien technology but what
makes us think this phone would be
waterproof maybe I'm both making up a
sin because I want to and answering my
own question this job will tie you and
not sometimes longer um don't shoot you
you were expensive thirty minutes ago
you use the same gun to fire off green
gloopy rounds if we're doing it your way
you to pull the trigger already I think
I found you a job okay so how does this
change the social services guys seeing
Nani nearly drowning Lila yesterday
isn't that the reason why he's coming to
take her away I need you to stay here
for a few minutes I'm gonna be right
back
she's six you can't leave a six-year-old
at home alone this is why you're in
trouble in the first place you have
learned nothing
three minutes ago Jumba didn't want to
shoot because stitch was expensive to me
make up your mind oh good they're home
alone again yay do your research when
buying dinnerware look for descriptions
that read plates made from unbreakable
ceramic that maintains lustrous coating
when hurled through roofing material
gantu captures lilo and stitch and
throws them into a jar which attaches to
the ship on the outside all this alien
technology and knowledge and you stored
on the outside of your ship yeah but
didn't the commander tell them that they
were fired and prison bound was it
implied that as long as they tried
really hard that they wouldn't be fired
in prison bound Blakely doesn't even
wait for an answer which should have
been met with confusion since everyone
thinks gantu has stitch look at the
right side you you won't have to yell at
anyone anymore I'm not sure I ever
realized how terrifyingly dark this
movie is are we sure Fincher didn't
direct it
you expect me to thank you just like
that very persuasive the entire reason
jumba helps is written off as a joke and
never explored again it's almost like an
ex machina where the screen writers
themselves are the god from the machine
the ship is flying completely sideways
to achieve the dorsal fin effect that no
one inside the movie would care about it
all because reasons nobody who watches
the skies for a living has noticed two
spaceships flying around earth the past
two days lilo is also still unsecured in
a solid container at the back of the
ship in case you were counting up the
sheets
arrives this moment's and the winner for
most non hilarious running gag and an
animated film goes to sunburned guy
loses mint chocolate chip ice cream cone
also this is the third time this Beach
bomb has been foiled and his attempt to
eat the ice cream and our movie bias
will tell us that he's never gotten the
chance to eat it but I choose to go with
the math and figure this guy eats so
many of these ice creams that having
three foiled attempts is just a
byproduct of his ice cream eating
frequency and look at me sure they
gotten 10 successful attempts since this
movie started I mean is it part of their
plan to run into the ship that lilo is
unsecured in I'm sorry that's just dumb
and all that's left in that container is
a lilo puddle nice this ship has a
control that allows you to point the
engines in different directions
my point is that's both what we do now
stay close
hope for a miracle that's all we can do
for Hale the other ship and ask for the
human child communication it's not that
hard
there is absolutely nothing about this
frogs relationship to stitch that would
lead us to believe that it cares about
warning him of an upcoming ship the only
other time they interacted this frog
watch like a dick this stitch got run
over by a truck nice are we doing the
a113 thing except we've already seen
that license plate in the Lilo's room
and on a fire truck considering states
won't issue the same plate twice you've
officially over easter egg
congratulations Disney you played
yourself no no King way I also spend my
disbelief for cartoon physics
occasionally but damn I am retiring you
captain gantu
Jesus Councilwoman sure doesn't make
snap decisions based on very small
sample sizes this is completely against
her character is introduced when she
asked the council to give stitch a
chance to prove himself at the beginning
of the movie even though he was
considered an abomination
I guess that experience turned her into
George Steinbrenner and for all you
crazy kids who don't know who George
Steinbrenner is just know he fired
people in the New York Yankees a lot
including one guy five times you'll be
lucky if you end up on a fluff Tron farm
after we sort this thing out
whoa oh they're moving given earmuffs
warning for the wee ones in the audience
this little plea will not only set
stitch free but also allow nonny to keep
Leela because why would earth or
intergalactic laws matter when
everyone's heart cockles are warm the
real laws were the friends we made along
the way also in an intergalactic Court a
judge would tell this girl that because
the council's decision to banish stitch
to an asteroid came before said contract
was
that whatever is contained in the
contract is known void including and
especially this shoutouts to the Florida
feature animation studio at California
and Paris feature animation studios and
disney-mgm this family is now under the
official protection of the United
Galactic Federation sounds legit
this won't be easy to explain back at
headquarters bubbles is gonna go back
and tell his people at social services
that Nani who was a horrible Guardian
suddenly became a great one after all
the reports to the contrary and he
probably can't bring up aliens without
being sent to a psych ward so either way
bubbles will be out of a job because we
want lilo and stitch to continue having
adventures convinced an alien race that
mosquitoes were an endangered species
well that joke just came full circle
didn't it how did that prevent the
aliens from attacking exactly why did
mosquitoes even come up in the
conversation also play clearly said we
are using earth to rebuild the mosquito
population like that was their plan all
one thing this movie does do an insane
degree is forget who had the plan what
the plan is and whether there was even a
plan in the first place in the real
world and yes I consider the world of
lilo and stitch to be 100% realistic
stitch would either be super famous or
super stolen by government agencies when
they find out all the things this
bastard can do lilo would have to go on
so many trips to infiltrate government
labs to get stitched back that it would
practically be a new mission impossible
franchise and you already have ving
rhames so it's not a stretch
[Music]
I've abandoned my child let's take a
look see hate your hair not likely
yikes yikes yikes and let me guess you
have a great personality right now it's
only a notion I think I can get money to
make it into a concept and later turn it
into an idea so long and thanks for all
the fish you know it wasn't like one of
those catfish things you see going up
the side of the aquarium sucking his way
up the glass lilo sometimes I doubt your
commitment to sparkle membership ah I'm
the one they called when things go wrong
I do what you my damn sight I'm gonna
get medieval on your ass
you look like an Elvis fan and Elvis man
should love
you